I know that J edgar Hoover's private
secretary Helen Gandhi destroyed a lot
of his personal papers after Hoover died
in 1972 it's possible that the grand
jury testimony was destroyed but they
didn't think that would compromise the
FBI they did a superlative job of what
they had I didn't think of it I think
that rather those files restored by
Helen Gandy must have involved sexual
things to do with people in high office
that River could use as blackmail
against them but I don't think that the
grand jury in this case is anything to
do with that
well they're no more questions Thank You
Anthony thank you
[Applause]
you're watching American history TV all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3 to
join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history each week
American history TV's real America
brings you archival films that provide
context for today's public affairs
issues this year marks the 40th
anniversary of the opening of the
Smithsonian's Air and Space Museum on
July 1st 1976 leading up to the July 1st
anniversary celebration real America
will be showing a series of NASA films
up next
science reporter food for space
travelers a half-hour 1966 NASA TV
program one of 13 produced in
cooperation with MIT and WGBH Boston
this episode examines the problem of
feeding astronauts in weightlessness and
on the anticipated long-duration
missions of the Apollo program when John
Glenn got hungry during his free orbit
flight in 1962 he simply opened the
visor on his helmet and popped a
high-energy tablet into his mouth this
pill a few sips of water and an
occasional squeezing of baby food from a
toothpaste container were more than
Glenn actually needed for the four and a
half hours he was in orbit the purpose
of the meal was to find out whether man
could even eat in a weightless condition
mealtime aboard those early mercury
flights was hardly more than a light
snack it even at that it was
considerably more sophisticated than the
brown paper bag and thermos diet common
to the earliest in-flight feeding during
World War two
since 1961 food scientists have been
hard at work studying and developing
space foods and measuring their effects
upon man the problems even for short
flights have been enormous yet as we
continue to launch longer and longer
missions into space entirely new
considerations must be met and dealt
with in planning and providing food for
space travelers how space food
scientists are doing this is our story
today on science reporter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm John Fitch MIT science
reporter today we're at the US Army labs
in Natick Massachusetts for the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration is
supporting considerable research into
the problems of space feeding the care
and feeding of an astronaut is by no
means a simple proposition elaborate
provisions must be made for a
life-support system and which men can
not only just stay alive but can also
function effectively while in space the
temperature both in the cabin and inside
the spacesuit must be kept within
critical tolerances the astronaut must
have oxygen to breathe and it must be
systems capable of removing carbon
dioxide toxic gases and other waste
matter
there must be an adequate supply of
water the astronaut must have food many
ways this is the most challenging
problem since the amount he needs
depends somewhat on what he has to do
furthermore he'll have no stove or
refrigerator no garbage disposal and
only a limited amount of space in which
to store what food he will require these
problems of space speeding were imagined
by Jules Verne more than a century ago
when he wrote a very entertaining story
about a voyage to the moon in a
spacecraft called simply the projectile
maybe because Verne was a Frenchman and
presumably appreciative of the good life
he didn't overlook the necessity of
providing his space travelers with a
menu when it was rather more elaborate
than we are able to offer our 20th
century cruise sea breakfast began with
three bowls of excellent soup thanks to
the liquefaction in hot water of those
precious cakes of bouillon prepared from
the best parts of prime Argentinian beef
to the soup succeeded some beef steaks
compressed by a hydraulic presses tender
and a succulent as if brought straight
from the kitchen of an English eating
house reserve the vegetables succeeded
the dish of meat and was followed by
some cups of tea with bread and butter
after the American fashion the beverage
was declared excellent and was due to
the infusion of the choicest leaves of
which the Emperor of Russia had given
some chess for the benefit of the
travelers and
me to crown the repast Arden brought out
a fine bottle of wine which was found by
chance in the provision box the three
friends ranked the union of the earth
and the satellite it's unlikely that our
astronauts will ever enjoy a meal like
the one Jules Verne's crew ate but to
find out what scientific work has been
going on in space feeding we talked to
dr. Paul a chance of the manned
spacecraft Center in Houston Texas we
have here a variety of the types of
foods available for both the Gemini and
Apollo missions here for example are
some rehydratable shrimp cocktail which
could also be a beef pot roast potato
soup which could also be a another
powdered mixture such as a pudding and a
beverage a grapefruit drink in this case
which could also be a cocoa just add
water and serve that's right
the bites we have are like the beef
sandwich which could also be a chicken
sandwich a sandwich compressed item such
as a peanut cube which could also be a
cereal cube of some sort and even a
fruitcake well you see that quite a
variety of items I think you could put
together a fairly well balanced diet for
the astronauts well we do put a balanced
diet together however it is based solely
on empirical knowledge or a good share
of it is and that it's based on the
recommendations for the average American
adult male these might not be what you
actually need in space well the fact is
that we do not know the requirement for
all nutrients for man here on earth an
example of this is for
vitamins certain vitamins and certain
trace minerals the recommendations are
based solely on animal experimentation
in other words there are no heal the
human data and you need this kind of
data you feel well yes especially when
you can't extract anything from your
environment if you're up there with you
either take it with you or you don't
have it so that one must study man and
must study these nutrient requirements
assists the requirement in humans under
resting or as we call it basal
conditions just what you need to stay
alive exactly and this will vary from
individual to individual and you must
study that facet of the problem also
this is before you can introduce the
element so in new environment that
you're going to have to deal with for
example the stresses that you're going
to have to deal with in this new
environment of spaceflight for credits
dresses well let me show you here we see
a series of stresses as one might expect
during a spaceflight
first the effect of g-forces as you
would get on liftoff or on re-entry as
done by centrifugation this is the
acceleration and deceleration during the
flight exactly here is a an impact test
as you would get on a hard landing for
instance
here we see vibration this occurs
especially on liftoff in combination
with the acceleration and it may vary
considerably with a type of booster
wouldn't be as violent as that I hope no
here at this level we're seeing the
establishment of tolerance limits here
we see a effect of noise combined with a
disorientation the noise of the rocket
motor yes and also just the noise of
friction as me for instance escape power
function here is a study of altered
atmosphere now this is a this is long
term type stressor this will always be
present 100 percent oxygen at 5 psi for
example or even mixtures of gases as
we're now studying now this is an
example of disorientation that one gets
with tumbling is probably well remember
in GTA 5 especially when the power is
off the spacecraft tends to tumble oh I
see anybody to get busy I suppose it
kept it up well they probably don't
notice dizziness but you may be altering
the vestibular apparatus especially when
you combine it with weightlessness and
this is the most critical I think and
the least known factor of the
spaceflight stressors certainly the one
of continual duration
I could see how some of those dresses
might make you lose your appetite for a
few hours but do they really affect your
need for food well the short durations
stresses are probably due affect your
appetite momentarily but I don't believe
they necessarily it would affect your
total nutrient requirement over an
extended period of time however
certainly those long duration stresses
the altered atmosphere the
weightlessness and the radiation which
we didn't mention a continued exposure
to radiation or bursts of radiation
might singularly or in combinations
substantially alter nutrient
requirements therefore one must study
what nutrient requirements are under
basal conditions and then what they are
with these stresses either individually
or in combination and then redo the
whole thing
in the actual environment of space then
with this knowledge we can truly say
we've established realistic nutrition
criteria for development of food systems
to learn about research into nutritional
requirements and how they are affected
by the stresses of spaceflight we talked
next with dr. doris callaway professor
of nutrition at the university of
california at berkeley we really do know
something about nutrients and nutrients
requirements there are some gaps in our
knowledge about qualitative things what
things are essential in what aren't and
we have even greater gaps on
quantification for an individual person
but really we do know something we get
along with a limited amount of knowledge
right here because we eat a wide variety
of things so something today and of
things tomorrow and a mixture of things
a given meal now with the astronaut
population we don't have this
flexibility open to us to cover our area
of less than precise knowledge because
we can only send a limited array of
things with them in and if we have
forgotten anything we don't have a
chance to go back and add it or for them
to get out somewhere in roof and and
pick it up on their own
what are these essential nutrients that
they must have the same nutrients that
they sell on a loaf of bread you know
it's protein for muscles and blood cells
and hair and
and minerals for your skeleton and some
soft tissue of phones and vitamins to
carry out metabolic processes the
regulator's if you don't have these or
you'll be in trouble eventually serious
trouble will be how do you find out what
a human being actually has to have among
these essential nutrients the very best
way is to go into the laboratory and
find out what a representative group of
people needs in our case for instance we
often work with students on the campus
would you like to see how we go about
this yes I would test subjects mainly
students in our penthouse laboratory at
the University of California at Berkeley
looks like a very luxurious way to do an
experiment the men enjoy count you look
out the golden gates for the window to
see there at the dining table and here
is a man doing graded treadmill work
which is a standard everyday for every
subject so that we can keep all things
to constant as possible and same time
he's running his German is he clouds up
at 3 miles an hour on the constant
treadmill
this is bicycle work and in this case we
are just measuring the energy
expenditure of the subject doing a known
amount of work on the bicycle by
measuring how much oxygen he is using
and how much carbon dioxide it puts out
we know what his energy expenditure in
his bins so you can relate all this
extra work to they know that's right and
we're interested then in how they handle
their food metabolically so that we
analyze a lot of end products and in
these experiments are trying to
determine total body losses which means
that we've analyzed things that people
don't learn what I like bath water and
whiskers okay once you know these basic
nutritional requirements is that all you
have to send along with the astronaut no
the weight of these essential nutrients
is really only a very small part of the
total weight of food that we have to
send the protein vitamins minerals
wouldn't weigh more than 3 ounces even
if we were liberal about it perhaps as
little as 2 ounces if we were down to a
minimum
another thing that determines this large
bulk of food that we normally
eat is our need for calories for energy
what do we use that for for everything
we're staying alive the basal rate is
what you use for mental activity and
heart beating and breathing and just
necessary body functions which you can
determine quite easily the basal
metabolism testing
probably familiar with how many calories
would that come to let's say it will
depend on your age and size and sex and
things like this but somewhere in the
neighborhood of 15 to 1,800 calories a
day and then in addition to that
whatever activities you carry out will
demand some more energy and in case of
the astronauts probably a rather
sedentary life being an astronaut about
2,500 calories a day or perhaps a little
less than that even know if you need
this 2,500 calories why couldn't you put
this all into a pill if after let me
take you could bet you couldn't swallow
the pill the most energetic food that we
could send would be pure fat which would
have nine calories in one gram and at
this rate we'd need something over a
half a pound to provide the energy
requirement and that would be the size
of a hockey puck and you know well if
this most energetic food is fat could
you make the whole diet out of fat thing
no you you couldn't for other reasons we
already said we needed protein on your
girls and vitamins in addition to that
you can't just utilize fat by itself you
have to have some other nutrient burning
along with it otherwise you get to
feeling oh head achy and nauseous so
that we must send some carbohydrate as
well so we've got about two or three
ounces of essential nutrients and
perhaps two or three ounces more of
carbohydrate so we're up to six to eight
ounces plus the fat tend to make up the
rest of the calories and chances are we
wouldn't send even that much fat along
it's not palatable and if we sent
anything like what you normally would
would prefer as a composition there will
be something more than a pound of weight
of dried food plus all the water and
oxygen and other critical nutrients that
you need
before spaceflight menus can be prepared
other considerations must be met in
order to find out about the development
of food for space and the way it is
packaged stored prepared and eaten we
talked to dr. Donald Westcott chief of
the serial and general product section
at Natick the US Army Natick
Laboratories and the food division has
been working for a number of years on
the development of food products for
military rations many of the problems
encountered in these developments are
also applicable to some of the problems
encountered in space feeding but are
there special problems in space I should
think there would be that you don't meet
on the ground there are great many new
problems which we ever had to overcome
in development of food products to
illustrate these we are severely limited
in the amount of weight and volume that
we can tolerate also there are severe
environmental stresses such as
acceleration deceleration by temperature
compression and things like that to
overcome some of these severe
environmental problems we have developed
a series of nearly 50 different food
items which can be used for space
feeding these can be divided into two
major categories they were system of
rehydratable foods dehydrated by various
means typical of which is freeze-dried
foods like these well you can get some
of these on the market now can't you yes
they are beginning to become available
commercially what is this this is freeze
dried peaches
this must be meat over here that's
correct that's meat and gravy some
vegetables I guess those are peas and we
have some corn these are just samples of
the type of items that are being used as
freeze-dried items to be rehydrated in
addition we have a great many bite-size
foods which are compressed dense
high-calorie source of foods typical of
which we have fruitcake mm-hmm the
sandwiches beef sandwiches and items
like toast how can you eat something
like toast in a spacecraft without
getting crumbs all over it we've had to
devise a system for coating the toe
with a high melting fat coating in this
case to overcome the problem of crumbs
in disintegration another system which
we are working on is actually packaging
the bite in a an edible film well this
isn't cellophane dinner no by no means
this is an edible film made from a
starch product and can be eaten as is in
fact it's actually nutritious now I can
see how you'd eat these bite-size items
just by opening the package anything but
what do you do about these rehydratable
items you can ver will eat them off the
plate with a knife and fork well all the
food comes packaged in a unit such as
this which is a meal for one day or one
meal for an astronaut mm-hmm inside we
have the series of packages this is an
example of a rehydratable package the
astronaut cuts the end of the package
off and then inserts the water gun
metering in the required amount of water
to rehydrate the product thus being of
adding water I don't see how you're
really saving any weight if you have to
add the water back again before you can
eat the food that's correct at present
we have to carry sufficient water both
for drinking and rehydration but we are
working on systems such as the using the
water from fuel cell by-product for
rehydration and drinking and also
systems for recycling water you have
here this is grape fruit thank you
yes this is grape fruit grain five
ounces of water two to five minutes
what's that well it requires a certain
length of time to ensure that the
material is we in this case the beverage
is dissolved in the water the package is
needed to aid rehydration and the
one-way valve prevents water from flying
around the capsule but that's the
one-way valve then how do you drink the
grapefruit juice after it's rehydrated
the other end is cut and a feeding tube
is removed from the package mm-hmm where
the astronaut inserts this directly in
his mouth mm-hmm
you squeeze it like tooth day correct
and drinks the product actually quite
delicious now what do you do with this
after three camber we'll throw it out
the window now attached to the package
is a germicide pill which is inserted
into the package after product is eaten
to prevent residual decomposition and
odor formation and fermentation in life
then the package is merely wrapped up
and put it in the disposal container
knowing the kinds of foods which can be
prepared stored and used in the
spacecraft and the nutritional
requirements of the astronauts
dietitians can begin to prepare menus
that are suitable for space to learn
more about menu preparation and
acceptance testing we talked to Mrs Mary
klika
a nutritionist at Natick you know dr.
Calaway has told us about these
essential nutrients we require and the
calories we need for energy and dr.
Wesker does display its own 50 different
what I assume were nutritious items to
choose from and how do you put all this
information together and come up with a
menu
well of course NASA gives us the
requirements for the menu and then being
linked to the mission is quite important
to us since it's more or less determines
what variety we need on the menu
the longer the mission the more variety
you need to assure acceptability and
consumption throughout flight I'll see
you in want to use the same menu every
day where a nutritious that get bored
with it okay cube or volume of the fluid
is important too
this is also related to the
the mission the longer the mission the
more concerns you are with the amount of
space the food takes for example in
rehydratable foods while they're very
acceptable they require much more cube
than the bite-size items now you say
acceptable do you know what the
astronauts liked in the way of who we
get their preferences before flight we
actually check out a menu with them to
be sure that they will eat and like
everything on the menu before it is
accepted for flight use well what other
factors do you have to take into
consideration texture of the foods good
menu combination whereas concerned with
sitting the astronauts wouldn't sound in
combinations of foods as the housewife
is and feeding her family d oh you
wouldn't want to serve peas and
chocolate sauce no matter how nutritious
they were we're also concerned with
little gas production foods that don't
cause the stress we're concerned with
color of food and we're concerned with
the acceptability of the food well now
how do you find out other than actually
trying this food on an astronaut its
acceptability we've test each individual
item and separately in fact these are
the booths behind this wall where the
testing is done the tester is given a
sample of the food then he is taste the
food and then he rates it on a card
telling just exactly how much he likes
or does not like this particular food
then we average these values and we find
out how the average consumer would like
this particular type of food would you
like to taste this the peanut killed the
astronauts like those we're good
thank you very much this is the life
support systems evaluator at
wright-patterson Air Force Base in Ohio
it was designed to aid in research
conducted to determine precise
nutritional requirements to evaluate
foods planned for long term space
flights and to investigate personal
hygiene procedures it is manned by four
subjects two of whom are required to
wear an unpressurized spacesuit
constantly for six
teen days the subjects activities were
under constant surveillance 24 hours
daily temperature humidity and other
environmental variables were checked
periodically by the chamber operators
all diets were scientifically formulated
and each portion was weighed to the
nearest tenth of a gram in order to
determine the precise balance between
intake and waste once daily food was
passed into the evaluator by way of its
airlock waste matter was disposed of in
the same way a three-day diet cycle of
precooked dehydrated food with
bite-sized compressed items and a
matching freshly prepared diet were
compared for nutritional value as well
as for subject acceptance the dehydrated
foods were packaged in metal foil
envelopes to retain flavor and freshness
the results obtained showed that
dehydrated and bite-sized foods were
very acceptable for potential use in
aerospace systems in addition to testing
the food itself the packaging storing
preparation and disposal means are also
tested to determine how well they will
work in the spacecraft as we've seen
foods for spaceflight may be bite-sized
freeze-dried or dehydrated as shown here
each item is fully tested by a suited
astronaut in a spacecraft simulator
before the food item is approved for use
dehydrated foods must be reconstituted
with water before consumption the supply
of water comes from the fuel cell of
which water is a byproduct a hose with a
nozzle is located between the astronauts
in this Gemini capsule mock-up as soon
as the astronaut has finished his meal
he inserts a special germicide pill
which comes with each bag into the
opening and mixes it with the remaining
food to [ __ ] spoilage the remains are
then stored for the balance of the trip
here the astronaut is opening a packet
of bite-sized items these may be either
freeze-dried or compressed foods each
item is thoroughly ground tested in
these mission simulators before being
allowed to go on an actual mission under
these situations technicians can
determine packaging false convenience
and handling stowage problems
compatibility with other systems and
general reliability before the item is
sent into space present technology of
space feeding is well enough developed
for missions of even a month duration
but new problems begin to arise when
considering an extended mission to
perhaps another planet to find out about
research in this area we talked again to
dr. Paul a chance for extended missions
the critical factors are space weight
and power this being the case the idea
the concept of reusing what you have in
the spacecraft becomes the optimal
approach first you would try to recycle
the water then probably the oxygen by
for instance recovering the co2 and
extracting the oxygen from it and the
regeneration of food becomes an
important factor however this has to be
taken in a series of steps probably the
first approach would be to compress
foods as which we are now doing and
therefore reduce the volume for storage
then we would try to introduce items
such as each prototype foods here the
nutrient defined diet this would be diet
would just be essentially ingredients
keep to the man's requirement
you'd leave out the fibers and other
things in food that you can't digest
anyway fine correct
and we would make it available as a
powder defeat reconstituted and made
into a liquid to drink or it would be
the identical ingredients in form of a
candy or even a cookie from that step
you could introduce into this synthetic
compounds synthesized essential amino
acids for it
or even foreign compounds such as some
products byproducts of petroleum
industry these might actually have more
nutrient value per cubic inch than
nature's own foods that's right that
would be the purpose of doing this and
of course lastly one would try to one
would get into the true closed
ecological system in the biological
sense which would be the use of algae
fungi higher plants bacteria or a
combination thereof where you would have
an essentially small farm in space or a
microcosm as we call it it would produce
your own food and you might of course
concurrently regenerate oxygen and pick
up co2 thank you very much Michael
example today we've been visiting the US
Army Natick laboratories in Natick
Massachusetts our guests have been dr.
Paul a chance of the manned spacecraft
Center in Houston dr. Doris Callaway of
the University of California at Berkeley
and from the Natick Laboratories dr.
Donald Westcott and Mrs Mary clicker I'm
John Fitch MIT science reporter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
next on American history TV Providence
College history professor Jeffery
Johnson talks about the rise and decline
of socialism's popularity in America
c-span's American history TV interviewed
mr. Johnson at this year's annual
meeting of the Organization of American
Historians in Providence Rhode Island
this is about 12 minutes
Jeff Johnson your study of socialism
focuses on the late 19th century early
20th century in that period he defined
socialism for us sure
socialism really kind of extended even a
little earlier than that actually there
were lots of European theorists who were
kind of talking about socialism broadly
and they were really kind of wrestling
with how do we come up with systems
where distribution of wealth could be
fairer a little more equal and so there
were lots of folks kind of talking about
that idea in the 19th century it was
really Marx who came along in the mid
19th century who said looking at it
historically actually that there is this
kind of march of capitalism and
ultimately he believed capitalism had
sort of gone awry and was really
exploitive and thinking about it in
terms of the march of history he really
believed that class struggle would bring
about a revolution and so for him it was
a little bit more of a revolutionary
immediate kind of socialism than the
theorists who had talked earlier so this
was really kind of in response to I
think the Industrial Revolution and so
these ideas from Europe I think started
to come to the United States and and
really start to change the political
landscape in some ways but that was
socialism to think about a classless
society where there would be a fairer
more equal distribution of wealth devoid
of an exploitive capitalism and so these
were ideas that took took a lot of
Attraction in the 19th century and then
I think through immigrants immigrants
and others started to come to the United
States in the late 19th century and gain
some traction so how does socialism then
manifest itself in American politics is
there anything unique about it yeah
that's a great question
it really is unique when it started in
the kind of the United States political
landscape it was in 1877
there was something called a socialist
Labour Party and again established in
1877 and it was almost exclusively
German immigrants so that wouldn't
surprise us given this context of
European socialism in the 19th century
lots of folks bohemian radical Marxist
who had read Marx and then brought those
ideas with them to the United States and
so the SLP or the socialist Labour Party
was on the scene in the late 19th
century and what's interesting about
them and having done a little bit of
research about them is they held all of
their meetings in German and so if you
didn't speak German you couldn't really
go to an SLP meeting and get a lot from
that but they were very dogmatic and
very sort of in line with Marxist
radical teachings that this revolution
and probably an armed one was inevitable
and so the SLP was on the scene there
were some other manifestations of
political socialism in the United States
and late 19th century something called
the social democracy of America the real
moment I think for socialist politics in
the United States came in 1901 with the
establishment of the Socialist Party of
America which really became the kind of
permanent Socialist Party and much more
inclusive didn't have their meetings in
German and anybody could join so they
were established in Indianapolis in 1901
at something they called the unity
convention which they believed would
bring together all of these factions of
socialists and as I answered the first
question you know socialism took a lot
of different forms and so unifying as
one political party was really important
so that was 1901 and the Socialist Party
of America then became a really
legitimate and I've argued in some of my
writing third party alternative to the
Democrats and the Republicans as a party
for labor as a times radical party and
and and really was on the scene after
1901 with pretty fair success and we can
talk about that a little bit more in the
next sort of fifteen or twenty years
were there any particular areas of the
country where the socialism was more
appealing than others it's a good
question a lot of my research has
focused on the Pacific Northwest and I
started to find that and historians will
define that lots of ways but I really
focused on Washington and Oregon and
Idaho and western Montana and what
struck me when I started to sort of
poker
and the sources was Eugene debb's who
was the famous face of American
socialism he was the Socialist Party of
America's candidate for president five
times once from jail which is
interesting and Deb's got really sort of
steadily increasing electoral results
with the kind of culminating moment
being in 1912 where nationally he got
about six percent of the vote just shy
of a million votes and that's
interesting and that's remarkable in and
of itself but what struck me was in the
northwest he got almost 10 percent of
the vote and so clearly something was
happening here we're speaking to your
question regionally there was more
interest and and more emphasis and so
what I argued in my book is that that
really it was sort of the boom and bust
economic cycles of the Northwest it was
the power of being involved in the
extractive industries they're like
timber and mining which could be very
exploitive of Labor the Socialist Party
found a very attentive audience in that
region because these were frankly
workers who had it pretty tough these
were long hours for low wages and in
often very dangerous work conditions and
so all of that I think culminated in
higher support in that region in the
northwest and that's what I've sort of
maintained that's not to say there
wasn't socialism popping up in in
pockets and other scholars have written
about Oklahoma the American Southwest
and and places like Milwaukee Wisconsin
which became a hotbed for socialist
politics but there were great electoral
games in in the northwest so part of me
what set Eugene debb's apart as a
candidate what was appealing about his
message oh that's interesting well I
think he appealed to labour and I think
it was and and scholars have written a
little bit about Debs in this way - Debs
could give a great speech and I think he
knew how to play to the audience and and
I think in some ways socialism at the
time might have meant simple answers for
complex problems if you didn't really
have to read Marx that closely you could
you could find a lot in that in that
kind of message and depths himself was a
former Democrat he had been a union guy
for the American railway Union and net
and then went to jail and was
radicalized there after the Pullman
Strike in eighteen
before and the famous mail injunction
and so he kind of found himself
radicalized and drawn himself to
socialist politics but but I think what
set him apart was being a great orator
being a rhetorician and and really sort
of spreading this message of revolution
and socialism which was attractive if
you were down and out and a laborer that
was having a hard time and so he he
ultimately I think emerged as one of the
voices of labor that's not to say that
the American Federation of Labor and
trade unionism and people like Samuel
Gompers weren't important but he had a
great rivalry with those kinds of the
folks kind of again trying to court
labor and the labor vote what was the
high point of the Socialist Movement I
think probably if you pressed me 1912
when Deb's garnered about 6% nationally
which at the time was the most of any
third party candidate in American
history and that was pretty striking I
think and pretty important so 1912 was
probably the high point and I'll just
say that there was always this kind of
sense with the Socialist Party and if
you read the old newspapers and
pamphlets of these kinds of things they
always believed that the next election
would be the big one
and that they would bring about the
final kind of march of socialist
politics in the US and of course that
never quite happened but again that the
high point being right around 1912 well
let me ask you about that was there any
lasting influence or impact on the
American political system that's an
interesting question III think that it
was a one of the first and most
important third party successes but in
terms of of great sort of reform and
successes I don't think we could quite
point to the Debs candidacy because he
didn't win as as a great sort of result
you know had he won I suspect things
might have been different but you know
my sense is probably not a great lasting
impact other than the fact that there
could be these dissenting voices and
those dissenting voices were important
and I've always maintained tell us a lot
about the broader American narrative so
I think there were there was some good
that came out of that just for the
political system we have such an
entrenched two-party system and always
have and we actually talked about this
yesterday on our panel
that focused on new perspectives on
American socialism and that certainly is
one of the nice things that comes out of
it is challenging that two-party system
well in addition to Eugene debb's who
were the other major figures in the
Socialist my good question depends on
who you ask if you asked me I would say
somebody like Victor Berger who was
elected to the United States Congress
from Milwaukee Wisconsin a good working
class town was really important and
served in Congress Congress in the
19-teens was later denied his seat
because of World War one and his
objections to the u.s. involvement in
world war one I think he's really
important and another person that I
think is is is really interesting and a
little closer to my research in my heart
he is a guy by the name of Louis Duncan
who was the mayor of Butte Montana from
1911 to 1914 which doesn't seem like a
huge electoral victory of any real
import but Butte in the American West
was the kind of quintessential mining
town and he was able to capitalize on
the labor vote and win that election and
actually serve as I think a pretty
productive mayor for those three years
in Butte representing the Socialist
Party and representing labor and so
there are those kinds of figures that
won those important elections and then
served as kind of the possibility or at
least examples of the possibility of
what socialist politics could do well
your research as we talked about earlier
focuses on late nineteenth century early
20th century what happens between early
20th century and the present day it's a
great question and an important one
because ultimately I think and I've
always argued that World War one helps
bring about a pretty quick end to the
Socialist Party's real prominence and
that's because the Socialist Party had
really argued emphatically against
involvement in World War one and to do
that would be to be perceived as
disloyal and so I think that cost the
Socialist Party a lot and those
objections of course were routed in in
kind of Marxist thought that all wars
were capitalist Wars and how could we
support such a war when really the
working class would do the fighting but
that came at a great political cost and
with the Sedition Act and the Espionage
Act of what we know is the Red Scare
it became very hard and very unpopular
to be a socialist in the way that it
might have been in 1910 in 1920 and to
really answer the question I think that
that's something that continues after
the Russian Revolution that if you were
to be a red or you were to be a
socialist or a communist throughout the
Cold War really this was not something
looked on particularly favorably and so
I think that helps explain why socialism
enters this kind of period of
unpopularity it's just not politically
expedient to be a socialist or a
communist and it has you know some some
grave consequences last question for you
how does Bernie Sanders fit into this
history yeah this is such a good
question and nobody was really talking
about American socialism until recently
and so people in my business are happy
about that I think senator Sanders is is
certainly the kind of candidate and I'm
not a political scientist but he's
certainly the kind of candidate who is
talking about socialism he calls himself
a socialist if we put senator Sanders up
against some of the folks of the early
twentieth century he would certainly be
in a very different camp in the early
20th century the Socialist Party was
divided between radical as I mentioned
dogmatic Marxist revolutionaries we
would have called them at the time Reds
and then there were tempered more
moderate socialists and they were called
at the time yellows and so they were
much more sort of a moderate and I think
he's talking very explicitly about
wealth inequity and he's talking about
the kinds of social programs that we
already have in the United States and
then of course lots of places perhaps in
northern Europe have that we might
consider socialist but he certainly
isn't the kind of socialist in the way I
think and who knows if we asked him but
I don't think he would be one in the way
that that Eugene Debs was or some of the
other really kind of ardent Marxists of
the early twentieth century
Jeff Johnson thank you very much thank
you very much you're watching American
history TV all weekend every weekend on
c-span 3 to join the conversation like
us on facebook at c-span history
this weekend on lectures in history
Georgetown University professor Maurice
Jackson teaches a class on the
philosophy of w eb de bois an
influential African American
sociologists author and civil rights
activist here's a preview
and so he challenged the idea of boogie
Washington which was to accept things as
they are to go slow to just participate
in industrial education and the best way
to establish the difference between
Booker T and W B was this poem by great
poet Dudley Randall ruled in 1969 the
height of the Black Power movement it
seems to me said Booker T it shows the
might a lot of cheek to study at
chemistry and Greek for mr. Charlie
needs a hand to hold the cotton on this
land and when Miss Anne looks for a cook
when I stick my stick your nose inside a
book I don't agree said WB is I should
have to drive to seek knowledge of
chemistry or drink I'll do it
Charles and Miss can look another place
for hand that cook some man rejoiced was
good in hand and cultivating in land but
there are things others who maintain the
right to cultivate the brain and so what
is he saying there it's the struggle
between industrial education and
advanced education between mental
education and the right to to knowledge
and and Du Bois and Booker T took on
this with belief
watch the entire program on lectures in
history tonight at 8:00 p.m. at midnight
Eastern here on American history TV only
on c-span three
next a panel of scholars discusses the
evolution of American liberal political
philosophy through the 18th 19th and
20th centuries they concentrate on the
ideologies of John Stuart Mill David
Hume John Dewey and Jane Addams the
discussion was part of a day-long
symposium at Grand Valley State
University in Grand Rapids Michigan and
is about an hour so much of this summit
is concerned with the intellectual
history of progressivism and
conservatism many of our speakers asked
how the ideas and arguments of major
political thinkers have made their way
into the cultural conversation have
shaped political attitudes and given
rise to political action
well our mid-morning session is
particularly exciting in this respect
the three historians before you Claire
right now are cenis Peggy Vandenberg and
Judy whips are going to discuss how
certain major intellectual figures of
the long 18th 19th and indeed 20th
centuries have affected and in some
cases may continue to affect American
political thought I'll introduce our
speakers alphabetically Clare Riedel our
tennis is a doctoral candidate in United
States history and a gebel dissertation
prize fellow at Stanford University her
research very well-suited for this
conversation interrogate the
transatlantic intellectual political and
cultural exchange from the late 18th
century through the Cold War today she
will discuss John Stuart Mill Harriet
Taylor mill and the coalescence of
modern liberalism in America from the
eighteen to the 1970s with particular
attention paid to the middle of the 20th
century
Peggy Vandenberg is an associate
professor of philosophy at Grand Valley
State University her teaching and
research primarily concerned the ethical
theories of figures of the 18th century
Scottish enlightenment Francis Hutcheson
David Hume Adam Smith and Thomas Reid
this morning she will examine the
reception of David Humes work in America
particularly by James Madison
Judy whips is professor of Liberal
Studies and philosophy at Grand Valley
State University her main interests
concerned American philosophy
particularly the intersection of
feminism and pragmatism as well as the
philosophy of Education the editor of
the four volume set jane addams writings
on peace professor whips will discuss
john dewey jane addams in the
development of progressive ideas about
education with that I turn it over to
our first presenter let me begin by
thanking the Hauenstein Center along
with the structure and staff for
organizing this wonderful event and for
inviting me to speak this morning thank
you so much for being here even at this
still rather early hour I should also
maybe mention up front that today my
talk is decidedly more historical than
political and perhaps is grounded more
in the past in the present or the future
it's also about intellectuals who
themselves or not politicians
nevertheless I hope it will provide some
food for thought as we consider together
the contours of our contemporary
political debate it's and landscapes and
how we might find some common ground
broadly speaking today I will look at
the place of the 19th century English
philosopher John Stuart Mill in the
invention of an American political
tradition in the 20th century to show
how this tradition is perhaps more
complex and historically contingent than
historians have sometimes allowed in
their struggle for the world the
Communists have one great advantage over
the West and that is the power to
generalize their position and their aims
they have their book Das Kapital the
West too has its basic books but it has
forgotten how to read them we have only
the dimmest idea of where we came from
so wrote Life magazine in 1949 and it's
lament fell on eager ears
year before an official from the Truman
administration sought help at Princeton
University for example in the project of
canonizing a liberal democratic
political tradition graduate students in
the politics department there were asked
to respond to the officials prompt that
as he put it the National Association of
Manufacturers has spent thousands of
dollars in an effort to prepare a primer
embodying the essence of our political
tradition but without being able to
produce anything hmm
more specifically the students were
asked to supply a list of books to
provide for an American and by extension
Western civilization the equivalent of
what Marx's Das Kapital had provided for
the Communists but just what was this
essence of an American political
tradition in the 1940s and 1950s one way
to look at this question and to answer
this question is to look at who or what
came to constitute the tradition by
turning as my own larger work does to
the influence of the 17th century
English philosopher John Locke and his
second treatise another approach and the
one my talk today takes is to look at a
more ambiguous case that of the 19th
century English philosopher John Stuart
Mill whose status is a liberal fit for
inclusion in a recognized American
political tradition in the middle third
of the 20th century was less clear Mill
celebrated liberal as he was an
acclaimed author of the great on Liberty
and representative government was not
Americanized in the middle third of the
20th century in the same way as his
fellow English liberal John Locke surely
this American ambivalence about Mill
bears some notice might it be because
Mill by the end of his life had written
favorably about socialism and that at
least some intellectuals after the Red
Scare and during the deepening Cold War
came to regard him as a fellow traveler
indeed a nuanced complicated liberalism
of the sort mill provided was not what
many American intellectuals inside a
vital Center wanted as I will suggest
today however not such an attitude and
not always reigned between the 1910s the
1930s the threads of individualism or
liberal liberalism understood as a deep
concern for individualism individuality
and the protection of the associated
economic civil and political rights and
freedoms thereof and socialism in some
sense and understanding the problem as
an understanding of
privileges of society or community with
specific methods of labor production and
distribution to better accomplish social
equality and economic equality so
individualism and socialism within the
body of Mills work represented for many
integral if complex components of
liberalism and even democracy itself as
such the combination of the two threads
and Mills thought was the very symbol of
the possibility of finding harmony
between individual liberty and community
well-being following the publication of
John Dewey's work on liberalism and
social action in 1935 however many
American intellectuals in part as a
reaction to Dewey's work itself
increasingly saw mill shift away from a
solid 19th century classical liberal
vocabulary to more open attitude and
positive stance towards socialism as
indicative of a fundamental and perhaps
irresolvable conflict within liberalism
and liberal democracy no longer were
Mills ardent defenses of individual
liberty and later in life socialistic
tendencies to sides of the same coin
rather they came to illustrate for many
in clear terms a chasm a deep split in
liberalism that could explain some of
the ongoing and fundamental problems at
the heart of American politics in the
late 19th and early 20th century Mills
increasing tendency towards socialism
over the course of his life was no
secret Mill himself after all had
written about his evolving ideas in his
own autobiography published in 1873 in
1924 Harold J Lasky the Marxist English
political theorist published a new
edition of it after extensive research
at the Columbia libraries in New York
City meanwhile students in American
colleges and universities learned of
Mills questionable status as a liberal
in some detail undergraduates in
Princeton professor alignment at waters
class in the 1870s for example learned
that as he put it
mill would substitute some form of
communism for the present state of
things and nearly 50 years later in the
1920s these same students were still
immersing themselves in a careful
understanding of as they took it mills
conversion from India
dualism to socialism in these decades
around the turn of the 20th century
however conversations about most
socialism often only underscored his
centrality to liberalism many Americans
not only confronted the tensions with in
Mills thought but embraced them as
productive means of thinking about an
ideology of individualism and American
liberalism itself a primary concern to
this group was unpacking for their
readers the nuances of knows philosophy
of individualism or individuality and
how Mill productively thought through
the at times tenuous relationship
between individual liberty and concern
for the greater societal good writing
for the philosophical review in the
early 1920s American philosopher and
Cornell professor Frank Tilly for
instance sought to as he put it examined
the foundations upon which Mills
individualism rests and to note the
phases of his philosophy which seemed to
be out of harmony with it and which so
often point to new roads such a study
Tilly continued may help us perhaps to
strike the proper balance between the
individual and society Tilly's
conclusion in short was that Mills
individualism and what many would see as
a later in life move toward socialism
were not incompatible nor necessarily to
be explained away but rather were as he
put it an opening of new roads of a
possibility for American individualism
itself three years later still in the
1920s Charles Street who has been an
Episcopal Episcopal student chaplain at
the University of Chicago also pointed
to Mill as a solution to the problem of
reconciling individualism with policies
intended to improve the general welfare
of Americans Street argued that the best
way to answer questions about the most
fitting relationship between the
individual and society or the state was
for his fellow Americans to turn their
attention to a careful study of none
other than John Stuart Mill in their
writings both Tilly and Street were
echoing the likes of bliss Perry's
understanding of the relationship
between individualism and fellowship
herbert Crowley's individual was our
Herbert Collins understanding of
constructive individual
and west Oh Woodbury Willoughby's call
in 1914 from his position of as
president of the newly founded American
Political Science Association to think
seriously about a social component to
individualism Willowby had declared that
although an American ought not accept
socialist doctrines when it came to
property production and labor he must
accept as he put it the socialist
general theory that it is the proper
province of the state to do whatever it
can to secure the true interest of its
people unrestrained by any a priori
limitations growing out of the essential
nature of political authority in other
words an individual's real interests
could at times be best advocated for by
the state itself in the 1920s as we saw
with Street and Tilly many American
intellectuals would employ John Stuart
Mill to explain these nuances of
individualism and to point the way
towards thinking about liberalism as a
means for improving society as a whole
in some ways this changed in the 1930s
then concerns about Mills socialism
began to crystallize as his ideas
increasingly came to be seen not as
multiple reasonable lines of thought
coalescing in the mind of a complex
thinker but it's two diverging lines of
thought that one must choose between two
reviews of John Dewey's just published
liberalism and social action in the New
York Times by journalists still
remembered today
Charles Chamberlain and Henry Hazlitt
service telling examples of such a shift
largely critical of Dewey's portrayal of
liberalism as resembling more closely a
socialistic scheme Chamberlain
proclaimed Dewey as he put it a radical
Democratic Socialist one-point
Chamberlain thought due he got right
however was Dewey's depiction of the
split within liberalism best dramatized
in the life of John Stuart Mill
Chamberlain learned through eating Dewey
that with Mill quote liberalism parted
company with laissez-faire in England
leaving open the question of whether it
had done or would do the same in the
United States writing for the New York
Times a month later Henry Hazlitt
finished his review of liberalism and
social acts
with a more rousing claim that in effect
through unpacking in the Korean mill
himself liberalism develops an inner
split mr. Dewey has what can conclude it
an outrage winds up by telling us in
effect that liberalism means socialism
these readings of Mills philosophy set
the backdrop for the Austrian economist
Friedrich von Hayek work on mill in the
1940s and 1950s which was secure in the
minds of many Americans the precise
nature of Mills socialism and its
origins in 1951 after more than a decade
of work Hayek a liberal perhaps in the
classical sense his complex relationship
to American political and economic
thought the historian Jennifer Burns for
example has well-documented published
with the University of Chicago Press the
correspondence between mill and his
eventual wife Harriet Taylor the letters
Hayek uncovered demonstrated Taylor's
overwhelming influence on Mills thinking
about socialism from early 18-49 as mill
worked on a new third edition of his
latest work principles of political
economy